- In the current moment we live in,
selfless acts hardly dominate
our political environment.
Instead, we see our
leaders dodging issues,
exploiting others to serve
their own self-interests
without much regard for
what's right for our country,
or for how we can work together.
Mayor Landrieu stands out
against that backdrop very brightly.
He fits the mold of a Profile In Courage,
not just for what he did,
but for how he did it.
Despite facing intense criticism,
like we've heard tonight,
heated political attacks,
personal threats,
he removed four Confederate monuments
from public spaces in New Orleans.
And he gave an eloquent
and compassionate speech,
the kind of which I have
not heard in a long time,
explaining to his city
and our country and to me,
why that decision was the right one
and why our public spaces
should be committed
to justice and equality
and provide hope and inspiration
for everyone who passes through them.